season three has been picked up
how oh my god wait what oh my god
what do you want me to do man you want
to sit around at home and computer to
turn himself
but i made the leap and now it feels
like you're the one trying to protect
yourself
i was in shock i was genuinely like
wait what because we had only we had
only
aired season one and then we shot season
two and then they said oh we're picking
up season three
and i was like wait what what happened
because that's
just so not normal i was like wow the
show must be doing really well
okay well you know you have a hit on
your hands apparently
it was it was unusual yeah to get a call
about the third season of the
show i guess based off the performance
of season one
yeah definitely indicated that you know
people were
flocking to the show and you know i
think we frankly
also were fortunate given that the show
launched just prior to covert and then
the lockdowns and so i think the show
found an audience of you know millions
of people all over the world
who are stuck inside and looking for
things to entertain them and
i think it was fortuitous ironically
that
out of that you know the show found even
a larger audience internationally as
well and
you know it's and it's nice i think too
given that so much of the content on
television these days tends to be always
trying to push the envelope about
what's the most dark sinister
crazy thing and then here's the show
that in a sense is almost old-fashioned
that it
harks back to very traditional values
and it's about
community and love and romance and
friendship and
you know just a bunch of good people
trying to be good you know
for the most part i think that has
struck a chord particularly with perhaps
the fact that there's
so much heaviness out there in the real
world
the show tends to offer a
comfort in a way that people seem to be
really appreciating and that
feels great we've been able to provide a
form of entertainment it's
kind of nourishing you know and and
maybe even healing in a time where
there's so much division and uncertainty
is there a time jump in season three
there's a minor yeah but it's not
we jump ahead to sort of get into the
meat and potatoes of
sort of all these other characters too
and i think what's really cool each
season tends to
open up all of the other storylines of
all the other relationships and new
relationships are formed and
so you know jack and mal are still there
dealing with
love and unrequited love and all that
and their obstacles but you see a lot of
all these other characters you know
as well and so it jumps ahead where
everyone's
in their own little private dilemmas
yeah it becomes more of an ensemble i
think
she's great you get more days off i mean
it was the greatest
creative choice ever you and jack are
wonderful together
would you ever consider trying again how
would you feel
about me having a baby
is there something going on with you
guys
what are the three things that you guys
would love to see
happen in season three
i think more babies is always good um
you know triplets would be good twin got
twins
i think if mel had quadruplets i think
we'd really even better ride
yeah all right setting the bar very high
juggle them that's how you pull the
child
you juggle children like that instead of
oh i clearly know how to juggle it all
[Music]